greetings
greetings greetings here we are
on planet earth doing a thing
yes with lots of other inhabitants
many of which have yet to taste the
undercurrent of unity
very true
oh man
get right into this oh let me let me do
this
yeah i noticed that it's falling a
little yes so is life
see this is a part of the fun
physical reality [ __ ] happens
the mic droop am i allowed to use
profanity on this show
of course okay do you think this is good
yeah you might need to tighten it a
little harder okay yeah sometimes uh go
in for the kill
yeah sometimes i careful with your
with your wrist i think i think
looks like it could stay up cool
it might be drooping a little bit but
yeah sometimes i uh sometimes i use two
hands on it
okay okay let's see here
[Music]
oh that's that's there's also that huh
let's
tighten that too looks like that might
be
standby stand by fam hold that
hold this yeah there we go that's good
let me act up there we untight
okay let's try that
cool yeah yeah cool that's pretty good
where to begin yeah wow
so keelan and i first
met in costa rica
at the shift into permanent alignment
retreat of bentino massaro
and
i had seen some of keelan's work before
that
but i hadn't really been in as much tune
with
it and then we clicked at the
retreat i had been going through my own
process that keelan was providing great
reflections
around and
then
now keelan's in la and he's
doing a bunch of different art projects
and photography videography
his own course on self-empowerment
manifestations stuff like that
so
probably um i know that you've already
spoken about this
uh before on on your journey but i do
think that it's a good
uh backbone for what we're gonna be
talking about which is
your own process of your own journey
and your
how you not only got into the the art
but also how you got into the
spirituality and how you
um your epic experiences with
manifestation
let's uh play there cool um thank you
for having me first of all and setting
this up
it's pretty sweet it's good fun play
with creation
um so yeah art for me
um is pretty much like
everything in terms of how i like to
play with reality
like it's like oh here's a medium and
something draws my curiosity to it and i
started from a younger age when
um my grandparents were muralists and
painters
and they would like sit us down when we
were kids and you'd start with a blank
canvas and then
uh you could create something out of
nothing and they'd take you on this
journey and you're like
your emotions get involved in it and
you're like creating this whole scenery
that lives inside your head but you're
putting it onto the physical plane
um so it would start with like a path
with trees and
fences and so i always was like
fascinated by the idea that you could
have something that was extremely
personal to you that lived in your heart
or mind
that you could put into physical reality
and like create
something out of nothing um so that
expressed itself as painting when i was
a kid and then
turned into drawing and also getting
into video like i remember picking up a
video camera when i was a kid and
just being like what like you can
capture something and then
like a relic and then show it to others
so that was like it was just natural
passion curiosity expressing itself and
video was
one that ended up sticking the most and
as i got older
um it was a fun way to express myself
too and you could like make funny videos
you could make like you could tell a
story
you could take people on a journey um
kind of like life is unfolding before
our eyes right now as a journey but you
could like create your own
and uh so it was like super fascinating
to me like all these mediums
um and so
like in college i want to go to film
school because i'm like i want to make
like epic
[ __ ] and like professionally um but i
also was in this
kind of like stereotypical
like shedding of society and shedding of
what i grew into
um simultaneously in college like i was
basically at the peak of
conditioning where i was like joining a
fraternity and i was like doing
everything i thought
cool kids should be doing and
simultaneously growing a desire for like
when i didn't get into film school
because i was too busy partying
um and flunked to class for the first
time in my life
i really was like okay hold up like what
the [ __ ] am i doing here if i can't even
go to film school
maybe i'll go to do business marketing
or something to accent my film but like
that was
a moment and a blessing in disguise
where i was like okay
so i didn't get what i wanted but it
made me say like okay what do i actually
want
um so as i was on the conveyor belts of
life like kind of going through college
one year two years
simultaneously i was like the dissonance
was increasing because i'm like i don't
want to go to school for business
marketing i'm going into
debt does this make sense
do i like the people i'm around what is
actually important to me and that's
where like the
it really started to kind of grow like
i'd always have a curiosity like looking
at the nice guy and stuff but like
that's when i was really like okay hold
up like what's important to me what
matters
um and i had to ask myself that instead
of looking outwards or like being like
oh
college is the right thing to do and
having those fun things to lean on
um so that's when i started to ask the
bigger questions
and if you are sincere in asking your
questions you'll find the answers
because you're
looking for them and so i'd like would
start stumbling across
stuff like um ufo videos
like on youtube and my alone time away
from my friends and
like it was like when you're alone in
your room you actually get to dive into
the things you're actually curious about
and when you go into
your normal societal structure of the
friends you've built perhaps
around an old paradigm that you haven't
left yet then you're like the distance
again gets louder and louder because
you're like becoming this new person
in secret with all these new interests
and passions and curiosities and
unanswered questions
and um so i would start to nourish that
more and like i said i started to find
ufo videos
testimonials of people who have came
forward from like different branches of
the military army that were like yeah we
had these
crazy experiences where these light
beings would like
shut down our nuclear bases and and so
i'm like okay
and like i'm pretty intuitive like and
these people in these interviews
had no reason to like lie about what
they were doing
they were genuine reactions like genuine
stories you could tell that they
it left like an emotional like scar on
these people and and them telling these
stories they were like
reliving the experiences and i'm like
this is real um
and i'm not learning this in school like
i'm not learning about like
extraterrestrials and like ancient
technology and
like hold the [ __ ] up like what's going
on here
so that curiosity and the evidence i
kept finding became
so compelling and evidential to where i
had no choice but to actually
be like damn well this is true for me um
let me leave school like and go back
home and like
you know [ __ ] what everyone else thinks
about it my family and friends because
whatever this is that's calling to me is
like way more real than
um anything ever could be so
and that was like the first moment of
like clear intuition i would say for me
because
it was like a nexus point of like a big
deal like you have this
character you think you're becoming and
you're going to college and you're doing
the right thing and your family approves
of it and your
friends think you're on the right path
and friends you've built along the way
are with you so like there's so much
identity
around that complex or that character of
going to college and getting a job so
it was a big moment where i'm like holy
[ __ ] like am i about to drop this
and uh so yeah i went on a walk by
myself
and i love walks because you're alone
and you're like you're just in action
you're
like in freedom embodiment and action
you're like by yourself and i like
had the space to ask myself the question
and there's like nature around me and
stuff and i remember looking up at the
sky and being like
like was the first time i felt like i
reached out to something greater than me
without knowing like i needed help to
like access like something like
beyond myself so i was like um i
remember looking up at the sky and i was
like yes like go
like put it down like explore yourself
um explore this and so i did
and okay well now [ __ ] now i'm in like
crisis mode because
my family is like what the [ __ ] are you
doing like you're leaving college is
this crazy
like you're gonna be the first person in
our family to graduate
your friends like you leave behind so
you have a legit [ __ ]
identity crisis ego death like a phoenix
rebirth which i've had
like many of i'd say but that was like
the first one that was like a
boom like punch in the face and
so then i'm like okay well cool now i
have all this space i put down all the
books let me like see what i actually am
interested in let me start
figuring out these things so then i come
across people like alan watts or esther
hicks and then
um like bentino and some of his
teachings and i was actually like
pretty had this curiosity growing
of like what's true and i was also
pissed off because i
was finding out that the world i was
living in wasn't true to some degree and
like
i was angry at society and the
government and the way it was all set up
and
as i'm finding out all these
transcendental truths about like hidden
technologies and ufos and [ __ ] i'm like
angry that i wasn't [ __ ] taught these
things
and there's like a grieving process for
me that was coming with that
so i was actually like literally alone
in my room working on a documentary to
like expose the the government or the
cabal
and like really being like i'm gonna
blow the [ __ ] lid off this thing like
and i'm gonna take like everyone down
with me because like this
field needs to burn like this is this
society isn't standing on truth of like
what could be possible um so there's a
lot of like
anger resentment like [ __ ] this and
and so as i'm working on that i'm also
coming across like law of attraction
teachings and manifestation teachings
and
um one of the things i can definitely
credit bentino for was like
in one of his videos he's like you know
by being angry at something you're
giving your power away to it
you're creating the reality where that
thing continues to have power over you
and you're actually being a victim and
i'm like
[ __ ] that's true you know so i
i was upset because that scrubbed my
whole idea for a documentary
um because i realized i was
disempowering people by making them
angry at something
and um even though it might have been
true
like it's it was irresponsible and what
i could do with my energy on the flip
side is something
more productive and conducive and
something that would
awaken possibilities in people and um i
could use that energy to create
something instead of
destroy something so
then uh yeah everything and that was the
first time i realized you could
um through these teachings you could
decide to kind of
feel how you desire outside of
circumstances
this was the first time i realized you
could like generate a state of being for
yourself that wasn't based on what you
thought was happening in your reality
um so that was like the
the very beginning stages of my like
spiritual uh quest and desire and
awakening
um and yeah from there it like was just
a strange
series of synchronicities based on me
following my inspiration
and joy and applying these manifestation
and like law of attraction teachings
that has led me to like travel the world
and do epic [ __ ]
and like manifest the exact reality i
desire and build a relationship with the
universe and
in a very tangible way for me because
you know i can learn all this spiritual
stuff but if i can't like grapple onto
it and apply it
and embody it and and feel it and like
integrate it myself
then it's not real for me it's just a
philosophy um
so that's really been kind of like the
foundation of my
journey is like these things are cool
but are they real
and so in my desire to find out if
they're real i throw myself into the
fire of
uh exploring them and then figuring them
out for myself
so you know today and always like my
intention is only to speak about what's
what's real for me things i've traversed
that i can actually back up with my
experience
so yeah i mean i could tell you some
like cool [ __ ] about manifestation and
stuff too but
this was awesome while you were talking
it just came up
that awakening higher possibilities for
people
and that one of the simple ways to look
at it is just
on this trajectory there's these choice
points
and that at these choice points there's
a bunch of
it's been taught like by bentino and or
not as this five finger trajectory
space and like you have this little uh
north star
up here you're calling your higher
purpose
transcendent noble aim that you're
dedicating your life to
and that some people haven't even
identified this before this is one of
the main ways to get out of the
mainstream in the first place
but if you're continuing onward
the same way you typically haven't been
exposed to
these higher possibilities and
keelan was mentioning that not only
awakening to higher possibilities for
yourself
towards these divine aims but also
opening these up for other people and
that being just
such a profound thing to do in service
to life totally and like as you
awaken authentic higher possibilities
for yourself you're gonna find
like if it's from the heart that it
naturally includes others so it's like
you're just upgrading reality like
you're upgrading this [ __ ] out of
reality
by like accessing inspiration and joy
and like infusing that
higher vibration into reality so um
but this is important because for me
it's like
you know you could stay on the the
straight line trajectory path you could
think you're in a physical reality and
you're like well this is my life these
are the only tools i have let me look
around this is my job this is my
families and my friends
you know how can i construct a better
reality for myself and it doesn't work
that way
like and the beginning of my spiritual
journey of like waking up to the fact
that i could feel however i wanted
regardless of circumstances woke me up
to the fact that
i could initiate like a feeling of
inspiration or joy in myself because
if you're like trying to make something
of your life with a shitty
vibrational attitude you're gonna get
like a low
resolution result like if you can
if you can and this isn't easy but if
you can remember that like oh yeah
we are traversing infinite parallel
reality simultaneously
and i can actually create whatever i
desire to create for myself
then you are naturally in a more
free-flowing vibratory state that's more
intelligent
and it's more true to the nature of how
this works because we came here to play
and remember all of this
is like it's more way more fluid than we
think it's not like this is so real
so um it's like oh yeah like it's like
children they [ __ ] embody the [ __ ] of
this energy like they're like awakened
to it
so yeah you first have to know that
everything is possible
and it is um so then the question's like
what do you want to do with that
how do you want to paint the canvas
called your life um
and then you can start to like generate
more [ __ ] for yourself because you
start to believe in yourself but just
this creation
so mm-hmm yeah
i also appreciated the
very close similarities between our
lives with that
that conditioned society
pressure around
finishing up a university path and then
kind of going into the similar path as
the friends
around us where there is a process of
that nine-to-five style essence
of um
earning money and then having a mortgage
starting a family
settling down in a specific area
and that is its own beautiful
exploration of life itself
and but we felt for us that that wasn't
for us and so i also left
in after sophomore year that was the
same time for you right yep
exactly it's so interesting and so for
me it was silicon valley and whatnot
and pursuing entrepreneurship and so
there was that similar style
you know this moment that we're talking
about you you have this
pressure from your family like you're
describing where it's like
are you really going to do this right
now you're friends are you really going
to do this right now are you really
gonna leave and then there's this
conversation that's had with um
the entire universe about your
trajectory and that what feels most
resonant and
and that those uh
those types of
ways of interacting with the game of
life
are are going to lead you to greater
fruits like you said if you come in with
a lower
energetic resonance you're not going to
get
as beautiful of something that's painted
on the canvas of your life
and so coming in with this higher
energetic resonance of okay i'm going to
open up
to awakening to these higher
possibilities of course you're going to
end up
leading to as soon as you
make the decision around that and then
dedicate yourself to it and
repeatedly go through the process of
making photography or art or video
or all different types of producing
creativity
that will feed back on itself
perpetually and then all of a sudden
within five or ten years
you'll be doing incredible things and
people will be like well
how did he do that
totally yeah
awaken the higher possibilities make the
decision
perpetually put in the work it feeds
backs on itself
and then five ten years later you're at
a place where
you've pursued what is in your highest
interest and we're rewarded for it
yeah yeah because you're like the
embodiment of that knowledge at that
point like it's almost like you've seen
too much
like it's like oh like i've seen too
much to ever
like settle on some level like i know
more is possible for me because i've
stepped out on a leap of faith and the
universe has caught me again and again
so i'd be a fool not to to push myself
to some degree and riding this flow of
inspiration and joy and higher
possibilities is like
you know i think in this spiritual
community like
um a lot of people think they're like
ego based
and like they want to suppress their
desires or
and for me there's like such a [ __ ]
humility that comes with following your
inspiration and joy because
yes you get amazing fruits but you also
like shed
the tree that you are like over and over
again
because you're forced to make sacrifices
or let go of things or
you know step into the face and the fire
of your family
asking you these harder questions and
your friends like leaving
them behind and like there's all the
shedding of these layers of the onion
that's actually painful but allows you
to
like transcend yourself in the process
so it's like
actually requires humility to let this
inspiration and these higher
possibilities guide you because
in my experience listening to them like
um
like sheds you more and more of like who
you think you are so built into it is
this like elements of
um freedom and letting go and like you
become lighter and lighter ideally
um so yeah but like once you believe and
you take a leap on something and you see
that reality produced for yourself then
it's like
okay like i see how realities works so
then you just behave differently and
like you're saying that
gap over time from you and say like a
standard joe might seem like how did he
get there well it's like you're saying
it's a bunch of little
steps and experiments with reality and
and like plays with your own destiny
where you're like
you start to realize how reality works
in a way for yourself
not as just like a fancy idea but it
like starts as a thought like when you
hear like a law of attraction thing or
whatever like
awaken higher possibilities everything
is possible they're almost like these
cliche bumper stickers until you
like have the courage and faith to like
test them out yourself and then
they're embodied and you're awakened to
that fact and you're like
oh [ __ ] so like with knowledge comes
responsibility in a way
um and like yeah like i'm still in the
process of
like figuring things out it's way easier
to like
you know plan out your life a to b like
college like marriage and
whatever but it's different to like the
path of like the journey of
self-discovery
um isn't for the like faint of heart
like i've encountered so much [ __ ] along
the way that's like
been very challenging and even shedding
myself the thoughts and opinions of my
family
and like friends of like i've literally
in that shedding process
it's like a shedding of tears it's like
a shedding of
letting go so yeah it's a beautiful but
you know you when you see the fruits you
know you're held like when you see a
beautiful reality produced for yourself
after letting those things go you know
it's like it's true and you like feel so
supported and you have this intimate
relationship with the universe
um that's like true for you and real for
you so it's
it's worth it
in some sense
yeah in order to
go from this trajectory to these
higher trajectories you
[Music]
have to do this process that keelan's
talking about where
there's a a shedding of
all of the um identifications
with this trajectory and so
that's what enables the space to open up
to this trajectory so
the identifications are typically things
like
keelan listed like the way that your
family or friends
think of you or your identity
that you've built around yourself as
somebody that was going to
finish this university path um
that somebody that was going to
find a comfortable job in the local city
afterward um and
then what opens up
even further is that this
this this these five fingers end up
you know shifting like this and so then
the highest
ends up becoming right here and that
um where you were what was the highest
is here now and there's a new highest
that opens up
and so one of the most interesting
aspects is that when you do
like this feedback process that the
north star
shifts into ever higher positions like
you know
the north at at some point the north
star becomes
a union with god it becomes a union with
intelligent infinity the one infinite
creator becomes that
and when you
empty of your self-interest the egoic
construct interests and you merge your
identity with life itself as
a as a shepherder as a steward of the
creation awakening
when you
fall in love with being in service to
others
so like these things are these things
only open up
when you've in a sense taken the first
couple of steps from mainstream
so you have to take the first couple of
steps from mainstream away from these
matrix locks that are kind of
holding people in place
uh and then once you begin putting some
fuel into that rocket ship
um you'll feel more and more of the
possibilities open up and at some point
um the rocket ship itself merges with
the kingdom of god within
and that is in a sense like the highest
possible expression of life is when the
shard the individuation merges
completely with
the one infinite intelligence itself and
and it becomes empty of its own egoic
self-interests and so
that that process um those like later
stages
can only open up when the
mainstream identity has been shed and so
that's a really important part is like
shed
like we could even uh
that's like
you have to shed the mainstream identity
in order to open up these higher
possibilities
totally and those are like you know your
identity mainstream identities like the
thoughts and opinions of others what
will make me look good what will
like it's it's like all the [ __ ] um
so and i can have a beautiful example
talking about how these
like how you said acting on the highest
inspiration in one moment leads to
another branch of possibilities i've
experienced that in my reality
um and this is important because for me
it's like
you can awaken these higher
possibilities not by looking so much at
physical reality but like
building a relationship with um the
non-physical so
and yourself and your intuition and your
heart
like your heart um because
a cool little story on like
manifestation and building a
relationship with the universe
um okay well first of all i'm the
universe in theory like
experiencing itself so i can trust my
inspiration i can trust what wants to
come through me i can trust these
desires because
in my experience like my desires are
something that the universe wants to
grapple with through the conduit that is
me so i can
accentuate my expression more so i can
like learn something
so it actually again takes humility to
go after these like
these higher possibilities and like
trust it to flow through the conduit
that's you because
um usually there's a challenge in there
there's like a hero's journey in there
there's like a
dragon you have to slay and
conquer to get the gold so as jordan
peterson would say
but um so interesting story
when i like was on a mainstream kind of
trajectory for myself like even two
years ago
because any one of these paths any
points can become
like um an identity or it can accumulate
mass that isn't authentic for you that
you're then
supposed to shed or throw away like it's
it's not forever
it's not like a whoo and it can be like
a whoa but
in my experience too doing those woos
can like lead you to
another like letting go or dark night of
the soul where you're like
have another shedding or like a run into
a wall like identity crisis again where
you're
left with nothing and you're forced to
kind of sit in empty space and
and the non-physical and until something
else awakens in you um
but so like a year ago i was like tuning
into the higher possibilities and when i
tuned into like a higher frequency of
inspiration what came to me was
okay i want to be traveling with people
i want to be creating beautiful art i
want to be infusing this creation with
artistic expression and and
possibilities and
so i had a and you're familiar with this
story but i had a bottle with a
piece of paper in it and a little glass
cork bottle and so i
pulled the paper out my mom had gifted
it to me for christmas and
i wrote down i want to travel the world
meet beautiful people
and create amazing things so i had an
intention i knew what i wanted
and this is what we're doing all the
time we're moving towards manifesting a
reality
that's our intention whether we realize
it or not but the reason a lot of people
don't see what's possible for them is
they don't get clear on it or even
believe it's possible to ask for it so
it's
i got clear on what i desired and then i
gave it to the universe or like planted
a seed into my subconscious mind where
i went down to the ocean at night and i
like
felt the vibration of that reality and
like even felt the weight of the desires
of like
the dissonance of like somewhere i
wanted to be and that i
wasn't and i like let it go and i threw
it into the ocean
and um and in that letting go i was like
cool
like i can let go now and and uh then i
just tuned into my inspiration and i
asked myself in a moment okay what's
like
if i were to die next week what's
something i could do what's something i
could leave behind using the gifts
um being aware of my journey and what
i've experienced
who can i serve the most and so my
inspiration
told me to offer 10 free
one-on-one calls with artists saying hey
if you're an artist
and you want some feedback on where
you're at in your journey
i would love to give you some
reflections um on where you're at like
your website like your art
if you're having any blocks expressing
yourself etc so
in doing that i posted on my social
media it was the highest thing for me at
that time what can i do honoring myself
my gift this life um so i posted on
social media
and that someone reached out to me from
ecuador and that owned a hat company
that i never met in my life
but um they were like i
i looked at their business and i was
like this is amazing you guys are
working with the indigenous and
making these beautiful hats you guys
just need to tell the story of what's
going on with your business
and do like photography videography like
redo your website
and they're like well that's great but
we don't have anyone to do that and i'm
like well i'll do that for you
like no doubt and inspiration through me
was like boom
okay i'm booking a flight i booked the
flight the same day for like two months
out
so then by me acting on my inspiration
like you're saying something else opened
up that i could have never seen coming
that was around the corner
and so now i'm traveling to ecuador just
by acting on that first inspiration
and then i go to ecuador and i meet like
um bentino and some friends there
that i had no idea that were there so
boom another one and i'm like what the
[ __ ] is happening it compounds upon
itself like you're saying
um and eventually you get out of the way
and realize inspiration
trusting it is like the most safe thing
you could do and like
um again it requires humility because
it's not always a straight path
it's like it's very non-linear and like
multi-dimensional
in my experience so yeah so like
dropping everything
and like asking yourself okay
like what especially if you're like
you're in a difficult place in your life
you're just like
um what like what can i do like now like
what would
what do i want to infuse into creation
like what and you ask
creation that question like sincerely
you'll always get an
answer um and it's usually not about you
it's usually about
using yourself as a conduit to to help
others or like infuse creation with
something some vibration or
to like lay your almost lay your desires
at the feet of creation
and um like give yourself over to god
and um and then some inspiration will
arise and you're like okay this is what
i'm supposed to do i'll trust that
and then you do it and then you like end
up in this river
of intelligence that's carrying you and
leading you to places and things are
unfolding that you could have never
imagined so
it's not so helpful for me all the time
to have such a linear
um idea for my life i've kind of like
given it over to like
my inspiration and joy and intelligence
and i think it will like mature and
start to take on like a
more um streamlined thing but
also who knows um but just to touch on
how when you act on your inspiration
enjoy it can lead you to a whole new
timeline
and it takes again humility courage and
faith to step into that
and you'll just find yourself in it
i love that by doing that so
i love how we played some tennis there
around
both yours and a little bit of mine
initial
rocket shipping out of the mainstream
forces and sort of what were
that those processes and aspects to the
journeys that then
ended up creating the next possibility
space after that
and so the the possibility spaces
continuously opening up opening up
opening up is really really
um one of the coolest aspects to
creation and um and i i'm always also
looking at the
the ones that i didn't choose that were
more linear
because i like to remind myself what it
would be like
to
to you know be maybe like
getting married in my hometown and um
getting a 30-year mortgage and i'm
getting ready to have some kids in a
year or two and um
never having um read any of the
spiritual traditions never necessarily
going to you know silicon valley and
understanding any of the cutting edge
sciences or
entrepreneurial technologies and so
like when i look at that path um
it in a sense it acts like uh it acts
like
um fuel not only to continue onward to
this
epicness that is currently unfolding but
also that
it it the contrast in a sense can help
people
um recognize that like if you are
feeling like you're in your
you know early 20s or wherever you're at
and that
um you're like watching this
or keelan's video or whatever the piece
of content is
and there's a moment of reflection
and you give yourself permission to have
a moment of reflection rather than
running the automated
program that you're currently doing and
if you give that
gift yourself that moment of of not
scrolling through social media and just
sitting just sit couch tree
walk whatever just be for a bit
and tune inward and just recognize that
you know this is your blank canvas
and like do you want do you truly want
that path that you're on right now or do
you want
something radically explosively
different and then
um
yeah that's that's um that was beautiful
how that was sort of
illustrated out as all of these
different um
progress points as well as um feedbacks
onto each other to go towards these
highest trajectories it was beautiful
brother
right on yeah um and i've seen that
operate in my life
like again and again just in regards to
like another short anecdote is
sometimes instead of pursuing what you
want directly again following your
inspiration is way more intelligent
because
when i wrote down i wanted to travel the
world and create
amazing things and like meet beautiful
people i didn't really pursue that
directly like i let that go i understood
that was my intention to create
the dance i wanted with the universe but
then i let it go and i said
what's important like what is my
inspiration telling me to do and that's
a conversation with the universe the
divine and my experience
and they told me to make a post helping
artists and through that
i ended up getting to travel the world
meet beautiful people and create amazing
things but i didn't
approach it directly so just as
important as it is to get
like clear on whatever that non-physical
like vibratory reality is for you that
you want to manifest it's just important
to let it go and let
the current of inspiration take over for
you and take the wheel so to speak
um yeah
um
one of the things that i feel like would
be great for us to
explore would be
we mentioned at the very beginning that
there's
maybe only a couple million
or tens of millions of people that have
tasted
this undercurrent of unity and that are
in a process of deepening their union
with it
and that is typically what
is shows up for people as they shed the
mainstream identity further and further
towards this self-empowerment and
manifestation pursuing
transcendent north stars callings and
then
having this highest union with god
the kingdom of god within you one
infinite intelligence
and seeing that everywhere you look
permanently and being in perpetual
service to that
and so let's talk about that last bit
because
what was your process like of the turn
inward and uniting with the kingdom of
god within
so um
you know i think it comes from
like uh admitting that to some degree
you're like suffering and a lot of
people don't
awaken or taste like beautiful states or
transcendental states because it's just
not a priority or they're not aware that
they're suffering they're not aware that
they're
like numbing themselves to some degree
or running from themselves or
um so the catalyst for me was like
having an identity crisis
and being really like [ __ ] up
vibrationally like holy [ __ ] like
contracting contracting contracting
family not liking your friends not
liking wondering who am i
and so you can like let it go and then
you reach this like
space of like not giving a [ __ ]
um so it's like the container pops
and um so yeah the catalyst for me was
was like was suffering actually um
and and then realizing simultaneously
that more as possible
it's like whoa like what do i want for
my life what do i want to experience
what i want to infuse creation with
um so and like curiosity like at some
point you're like
interesting like when you taste like the
non-physicality of
creation then you're like huh
like how deep can i go what is this like
non-physical world i can explore within
myself
um so again and that if that's authentic
for you and it's like
a desire for you then you're gonna make
it a priority to experience that
and for me it was through the contrast
of experiencing the dark and like
finding out darker truths about the
world and like um
and like myself and like and uh so it's
like well damn
um there was like one day i was so deep
into conspiracy
theories like i literally thought the
earth was flat
and it was like the most depressed like
i've ever been in my life i like went
out on the grass and i was like
what the [ __ ] like can i trust humanity
like what is this
like um and it was only through those
like darker moments that i was like
really seeking the light and so
then it was like i began to experiment
with like meditation sincerely and like
play with
um evoking like giving myself what i
desired
from creation instead of like asking
from it like for like
through creation or needing something to
give me that feeling it was like
that's when i began experimenting with
um guided meditations or visualizations
and like
and like uniting myself with um like a
great occurrence
and like feeling love and
things um with just
like by myself like through the sincere
desire and intention to evoke that
experience for myself
um so ironically some of the most like
beautiful moments of
of uniting with god have been when i
needed him the most and like needed
to awaken that the most um which is why
i think catalyst is such a big part of
this
physical reality it's um it's not a
tuned
we're meant to like dig through the mud
and i think our lives are meant to
fall apart so that
we can remember that it's not in those
things and again that's where this path
of like empowerment manifestation kind
of comes with the sense of humility is
because
you're awakening to higher possibilities
you're following these higher
trajectories and along the way you start
to accumulate an identity around that
naively so um and then you're like
and then if it comes crashing down
because that identity carries weight and
it like boom can
smack you down again to like earth where
you're left with nothing but yourself
and then like then you start over then
you open
you're you're forced to open your heart
again to
to heal to um say okay god like what's
next like what is the next journey of
exploration like
what do you want to experience through
the conduit that is me and it's like
i've heard this quote recently that's
it's familiar to me and everyone it's
like lego and like god
um but it's traversed like a new depth
for me currently because it's
an intelligence takes over when you when
you let go and you're not so
like um trying to move things around
like in physical reality but igniting a
higher flow and i think that's what
we're here to do
and the reason people don't become like
in my opinion
accentuated expressions of themselves is
because it it takes
like falling over and over again and
finding out who you are
and like putting on different coats and
saying like hold on there's something in
this person i see that
ignites my curiosity and passion so i'm
going to try this codon and i'm going to
own it
and then falling like like
like chasing and falling so you can find
out like okay what is this
this expression that i am what is it
where is this river in me that operates
effortlessly for me
it's like okay it can get ignited in
conversations like this where
i'm talking but it's not like i'm trying
to talk it's like
there's a river that i'm kind of
surrendered to that it's like okay
operating through me
same thing with art it's like this like
trusting your passion and inspiration
and curiosity to
just ignite the life of your dreams for
you is like
where the [ __ ] sauce is because it's
like
um yeah it's way more intelligent than i
could ever be
and like that's why i let art take the
wheel and i'm like
awakening when i'm like creating a video
i'm like it's almost like you're
this conversation with the divine where
you're like what is it like that
you're looking for this thing you're
you're on the edge of creation
with art and it's like you're learning
as you're like experiencing it
as you're creating it it's like
revealing itself to you simultaneously
so like
that's why i think art is so beautiful
to me because it's like you're
you're on the edge of creation you're on
this edge of vulnerability and
discovery simultaneously um and i like
to approach my life like that too
so um it's a perfect analogy
yeah so it takes the form of artistic
expression for me
usually um but then you again realize
art
like life is a canvas and you you can
literally do whatever you want
like like i had the intention to meet
like what's been more interesting for me
is
recently is like you know again in the
spiritual community we have this idea
that others are awakened and others
aren't and
that some degree that's true but it's
like i'm also interested in the ones
that are playing god without realizing
it and
we all are doing that we all came here
and put on these cloaks these masks of
forgetting and we like
don't know why we're here like and we
came here to forget
there's a veil so there's like people
playing god innocently and and
beautifully and ones that are
not even awakened to spirituality you
know the spiritual journey
is built into creation itself so it's
like you can't come here and not awaken
to more of yourself like you can
you can forget more of yourself but
still your this intelligence is guiding
your life and
you set up enough things along the way
to awaken to more of yourself so
even if you threw out every textbook in
the world on the spiritual journey you'd
find it in your own experience
and it just comes through like like
following
following following it like uh
so yeah
yeah this is way more intelligent than i
could ever be and then
giving your life over to that and you're
and accepting like when i'm doing things
that
inspire me that i'm curious about i'm
not asking myself why am i
why does this inspire me or judging
myself like oh this is your ego
trying to chase something it's like no
this it's no different when you're in a
flow state with anything whether it's
cooking for you whether it's creating
something whether it's
editing a video you get into this or
speaking you get into this flow state
that carries itself
and like that's the river of life that's
like the river of intelligence for you
and the only time you can't align with
that is when you're
you have you haven't really asked
yourself what you desire yet and you
you're taking on something that's not
authentic for you and it feels heavy and
not that you're not going to
encounter challenges in this river of
intelligence
um because you do
and in my experience awakening to higher
possibilities and chasing them is this
river
and you're going to bump into everything
in that path that are rocks for you
or like where you receive reflections
and you're like ah [ __ ] like
damn now this repressed childhood memory
is coming up
like from when i was five like ow what
the [ __ ]
because in this higher vibratory
environment those things can't survive
so they you're meant to shed them you're
meant to experience them you're meant to
awaken to them you're meant to let them
go and transcend them
like the phoenix so to speak so it's um
yeah yeah it's not for the faint of
heart
that was so awesome when you were
unpacking this
role of suffering in the process because
um in a sense the more that you can
become sensitive to where you
suffer is where you can
learn grow integrate heal transcend
experience more peace and joy experience
more of these higher possibilities and
so you can use
suffering as a drill sergeant of
awakening like continuo says and i love
that way of looking at it as well
and so i loved that component to it
and then the other component
to it that i loved was that especially
if you
just sit with like a blank sheet of
paper
and then you're just sitting with it and
then you have some
like markers and
if you notice that the energetics in
that moment
is like you know
that that this is about to be
something that i don't yet know what
it's going to be like in that
it's very similar when you're in the
premiere or final cut and you have your
timeline and that you
are you know dragging in some assets and
you're moving them around and you're
figuring out music and all this type of
stuff it's really beautiful because
you're moving along frame by frame and
it's being made
and you're just watching this you know
piece of r or like you know michelangelo
and the statue of david right you just
you have this process of like you know
kind of what you want this final asset
to
be like a little bit in general but you
have no idea what is really
how it's going to unfold um
and so that's a very unique experience
with art and i think it's really
important for all humans to sort of
undergo that
and then to draw the analogy from that
to themselves
and then to realize that they are that
same style of artistic creation
like the blank canvas that you draw
whatever
on is your life as well so it's like a
microcosm to the macrocosm
totally that's so cool and i love that
analogy of even like editing a video
like you know what you're going for and
you have this feeling of what you wanted
to represent but like along the way you
run into
like all these little ideas and
inspirations just by playing
like like this clip oh like this is
perfect and it's like boom this
inspiration or like intuition is like
guiding itself to this
final product that like usually
represents like what you intended but it
could be like something who knows like
different altogether that's like even
more epic
that you couldn't have imagined um so
yeah yeah
maybe one of the ways that we could uh
visualize this
so it's like there's there's infinite
possibilities
for both the blank canvas that you're
making art on
and there's also infinite possibilities
for your life
totally totally yeah then it's like
what's gonna happen
it's like so it's like a mini
representation of
of yeah the thing called your life you
could say like you could even put
a canvas down to a week of your life for
like a month of your life and
um yeah what's the most important for me
is to awaken to those infinite
possibilities and realize like this is
something important too that i'm
pretty big on is like you know
there's a certain degree of like
self-honesty in regards to
what's actually true for you like for me
i've
um experienced stages of my life where
i've been alone and like loneliness was
like a concept
or like a theme i was supposed to
wrestle with or
grapple with and i saw it as an
opportunity to sit with myself more and
like
awaken to like non-physical states or
meditation or
to get to know myself and then there's
also points where i'm like hold on
this whole um theme seems to be
exhausting itself
and what feels more authentic or
expansive or expressive is to be around
other people and get reflections and
like co-create something and dance with
other people's energies and
oh yeah it's not like my life is what
happens i think too is people end up
putting on these
coats or themes um of say like
loneliness that could be beautiful
for you to go on this journey of
self-exploration and an opportunity like
none other
um but then it's like you can if you
gain enough momentum or that becomes
like a status quo
for your self unconsciously like you can
think
you're like trapped in that or that's
the way life is but it's like oh wait
hold on
okay infinite possibilities this desire
in me honestly
is starting to awaken to the fact that i
want to be around more people and i want
to forge new friendships and experience
more things and
um so then it's like okay cool i'm going
to make that my intention and then
trusting reality will deliver that
to you through you and uh and then you
act on the inspiration as it arises
because if that becomes your intention
to interact or build like a new uh group
of family or friends
around you then like and you're
embodying that
the fact that that's a possibility for
you then your intention becomes
you become like a magnet to those
parallel realities of like
huh since you are that embodied because
you know it's possible
you'll be at the coffee shop and
naturally through you
bless you um you'll you'll just have
this
inspiration to talk to the person next
to you who knows like um
and you're just like start a
conversation and then like you start
weaving that
intention into your life only because
you know it's like it's
like it's what's possible so it's like
oh cool um so self honesty is a huge
thing too
because i think a lot of times um for me
i've fallen into like
um and i think a lot of people i've seen
this and a lot of people around me
like family and friends where they use
spirituality kind of like we're talking
it's like a band-aid or like a
something to like a like a medication or
a painkiller
for bypassing their true desires and
their actual desires
like um and maybe it's only because they
need the contrast in their life of that
suffering like i'm saying to
uh saying earlier how they're wrestling
with
a life that's not in alignment or lower
vibrational jobs or realities
so that they can turn to spirituality
and their spare time to experience these
higher states but
once you realize you don't need to
create like a shitty life for yourself
to experience
the beauty of it then you're like you
you can start to be like oh wait hold on
um
i can create a life that's inspiring and
maybe has challenges but they're worth
it
because they might be aligned with my
calling and
i don't perceive it as hard work in the
moment um so
self-honesty is huge because it's like
yeah you can use meditation to access
these higher states and
unite with god but then you do have to
come back to physical reality because we
embodied ourselves here
and then the question becomes like well
what do you want to create for yourself
and for me
that answer was always been like okay
well let me let inspiration move through
me and be honest about like what it is i
desire
knowing it's possible and um and then
create that for myself
and then it becomes way easier you're
resting on a
physical reality where the foundation
has a higher vibration because you've
chosen to create that for yourself
to where you're not using meditation as
a
like vacation it's your foundation and
your physical reality is something
you've created
um out of will and it's like inspiration
so it's like something you can rest on
and then you're like you're like almost
resting in that
your reality becomes infused with a
higher vibration instead of meditation
having to be something you go to escape
to
it kind of becomes simultaneous because
these higher vibrations are operating
through you so then they're they're
painting that into your canvas
um and you're experiencing it
simultaneously
um and then like if you have these
moments which is
which are inevitable um kind of like i'm
a big fan of jordan peterson talks about
like
we're gonna encounter suffering like
we're gonna lose loved ones we signed up
for
[ __ ] like death is a part of physical
reality like obviously
you can shift your perspective from the
mainstream to where you can look at
death as like a celebration of life but
there's still
there's parts of you in the human ego
that are attached to people and things
and family and loved ones and it's gonna
hurt
um inevitably so
like um when things come crashing down
you know too so to speak there's there
is this
i mean like every time i think i've had
it figured out like i've
i've definitely been humbled at the feet
of god
again um so it's not like
i wish there was like um
like a one fix all button but in my
experience
i've gained faith and conviction and the
fact that i can experience like
states non-physically that are beautiful
but i've also again and again
um even through this path of following
my inspiration and excitement had things
crumble down around me or like lose
things or lose friends or like
lose the journey and you lose the
identity along the way
um that ignites like grieving or like
loss or like
and there's something beautiful in that
too and i i think we came here to
experience that
and um you know there was i was at a
retreat this weekend
and i've been to meditation retreats
where it's only
non-physical focused uh things but this
was all about kind of like
embracing the human nature of what we
came here to experience and dance and
poetry and spoken word and
even as i got into a room full of people
um yesterday and wrote a poem
and spoke it to 20 people my like legs
for a second were like shaking you know
like
and so i'm like huh that's interesting
like you know
what is that um so
there's something about throwing
yourself into the unknown
that again requires the humility and and
being like what like what
like yeah i can do all this meditation
and stuff but how well can i dance with
this creation how well can i
like put myself out there in weird
situations where i'm forced to grow but
also see where i lack
something simultaneously because and
then i'm like well what is that
like why was i like shaking in front of
people
um and do i want to master that now
let's say like i want to
be able to stand confidently and uh
express myself in front of a like group
of people
um because there's something that i'm
acknowledging there that's an end
balance let's say
that um that like i'm like oh
hmm like i see you um
and for me too it's like there's always
been this balance of
um knowing that i'm there but
i'm not there yet to some degree like
for me i always sense an intuition of my
fullest expression
like whether it's in my my physical body
and how i can create it
like uh shape it mold it through
physical exercise or something
like i'm aware that it's not where it's
supposed to be but that i'm always where
i'm meant to be
and that um so for me it's like yeah you
can think everything's perfect and
obviously it is
but there's also this
subtle tone that's like a very
like faint background noise like call it
your intuition it's like
and it's like i feel this non-physical
um like calling of like my fullest
expression and i'm aware of what that
feels like and looks like and then i'm
not actually there yet because i haven't
put myself in the situations where i've
been forced to grow
or to evolve or wrestled with reality in
certain ways where i've learned those
lessons or
like those catalysts um so
for me too there's also a balance of
like in my journey there's also a
balance of like
realizing i'm there but i'm but i know
and i have a sense of this intuition of
what my fullest expression looks like
embodied and i can sense that and i'm
always heading towards that
so i have an awareness that i'm not
fully crystallized
um and that shows up as catalyst in my
like physical reality like
me reading a poem and my legs shaking in
front of a group of people i'm like
what the [ __ ] was that like weird um
so it's like oh interesting i want to
dance
with creation so that like um
because you can you know i think there's
a saying like you can become enlightened
and there's something like in your room
it's easy to become enlightened when
you're alone in your room but like
how well can you dance with like the
devils of this world so to speak it's
like
um it's easy when you're alone but then
the the practice for me
comes when you kind of like pick up the
sword and dance with creation and yeah
um that's when you're like knocked off
your [ __ ] kilter
and you're like whoa this is weird whoa
this is weird so it's like uh
dancing with creations just is it's such
a beautiful [ __ ] catalyst that we
get to experience um and that's where
like the rubber meets the road
in my experience as well so totally
totally we have to weave
what we've
learned and ascended into
the civilization into the mainstream um
that's the bodhisattva that's the most
interesting highest expression of
the buddha or christ or laozi or whoever
is that you take these profound
understandings and you weave it into
the masses um
and i feel like
one of the nice things about this is
that it kind of plays
into um imagine as well which is what we
have we've been talking about quite a
bit but it's also the title of the
um the self-empowerment and
manifestation workshop
that is uh coming up it's like a master
class that keelan's
um putting together the curriculum for
um and shepherding people onto and so
it's kind of cool because when you
when you sort of visualize uh
your life as that infinite possibility
space and then you undergo this
like very imaginative process of
seeing that like it's both perfection as
it is
and yet it's also perfecting even the
one infinite creators on a journey of
exploring infinite possibility and so
then you you see it
and then you are in a relationship
to sacrificing short-term gratification
for something in the long term that is
more transcendent and more
more you and that probably be a good
um way for for us to um
pass this last bit as talking about the
imagine and talking about the workshop
master class
cool yeah so this again
i was sitting on the back porch here
actually and
like having a conversation with the
universe like playing with the vibration
of curiosity and like
what my inner child so to speak like oh
like
like what's next like what do you want
to do like how can you play with
creation
um and letting that guide my actions and
it's like okay well when i
stay true to what's true for me i'm like
um
it's like an experiment so imagine the
idea for it is an experiment with
kind of the quantum field to show you
what's possible
so like the idea is like if you leave
not
awakening to the fact that either more
things are possible or that everything
is possible then
i like failed the mission
and uh and this is using things in my
personal experience
like these things i've talked about like
acting on your inspiration getting clear
on what it is that you desire so like
in this course a lot of people don't
manifest
what they want because they don't ask
for what they want because they don't
believe it's possible
so that's like they're on this they're
not aware of the awakening of
possibilities
so okay first foundation this is an
infinite universe you can
create whatever it is you decide to
create for yourself um where are you
operating vibrationally
currently so like first of all awaken to
the fact that everything is possible
then have the courage and humility
simultaneously to to ask for that
um because you are the universe
experiencing yourself and the universe
wants for you what you want for you
that's why you're creating the life that
you're creating
it's because you want it um so but if
you can get honest with yourself that
this actually isn't what i would desire
which we'll do in this course
um so you'll awaken to that inform the
possibilities we'll get clear on like
how to access your intuition and those
possibilities for yourself and
once you're awakening to those things
you're like you can fearlessly ask
yourself
okay what is it that i desire and
there's this
and we'll find out how to answer that
question for yourself authentically
because there's these
gifts you have these natural expressions
you have these things you've
came here to learn where and not a
physical reality will represent that to
you like a certain reality will
represent that to you and you'll get it
in images or visions or feelings
and then we'll again fearlessly and
courageously ask the universe
for that through this like ritual or
this dance with the universe where
you're
you're forging an agreement with
creation saying hey i trust in you to
give me this
and you're putting those desires into
like a bottle or a balloon
and like letting them go and and letting
them go symbolically and for yourself
too and saying hey like this is what i
want
and your in my experience planting that
seed into the subconscious so that can
manifest in your physical reality
because by letting it go you're letting
it go but you also got clear on what you
want so you have this
you form this relationship in this
course with the universe where you
you become aware that you're not alone
and that you are supported um
and we'll be so then we'll let that go
we'll learn how to follow our
inspiration and we'll be
um doing this thing where we're kind of
experimenting with the quantum field
where
a lot of the channel texts that i've
come across like law of one
or even like becoming supernatural by
joe dispenza
there's this i mean when you play with
the quantum field
essentially there's um there's like
irrefutable proof that
when a group of people hold the same
intention that they can literally move
mountains together
um because reality isn't physical it's
all vibration and when we
charge an intention as a group with a
feeling state
um then we can manifest things like
quicker
so it's kind of like a quantum
accelerator it's the idea for this
imagined course is
we each get clear on what we want and
then we do these group meditations where
we see these things coming to fruition
having a relationship with the quantum
field or the universe knowing that we
affect
physical reality together and then we
see those things like
these possibilities coming true for each
other um
so it's a it's and surrender is just as
important through this entire course
because what i want people to realize is
it's not in the manifestation it's like
there's this natural flow of trust you
can start to build with the universe
where you ask it
for that thing and then you become the
embodiment of trust knowing that it's
going to come into fruition
just by listening to your inspiration so
it's not about wanting and waiting it's
about
wanting and knowing that okay this is
how reality works
and then it's like just the the blooming
of the fruit
um and then the it will fall off the
tree
and you'll experience the manifestation
of that um
in your physical reality so it's it's a
it's an experiment with the quantum
field and
the universe it's a the intention is to
allow you to build a relationship with
the universe to know that you are held
and to know that you're not alone in a
very like
visceral sense and to experience more
possibilities
as a group container um so
yeah it's um it's like a date with the
universe where you get to
play and paint whatever it is you desire
to let those things go and then to see
them made manifest in your
reality just to kind of get a taste of
how this works
uh at least based like from my
experience based on my experience
um so that's the gist of
it yeah
when you said date with universe it
reminded me of
tony robbins has a date with destiny as
one of his programs
and that there's a lot of like similar
similarity between what you were saying
and what he's
been teaching in his programs and also
in what we drew in our
visualization with the infinite
possibility space
and um yeah shepherding adepts
uh stewarding people on a journey
of entering into a container to
more um just like they learned a
language in school it's like
learning the the infinite possibility
space and learning manifestation and
learning
intention and all that type of stuff
it's it's
really beautiful yeah and the vibe of it
is like
playful and it's like experimental it's
playful it's like
inspirational it's like planting a seed
of like hope
faith like into something larger than
yourself trusting that you are
carried um so it's like it's not
so serious it's uh
yeah it's like it's like playing with
creation that's what i kind of call it a
date
it's meant to be like let's see what
happens together in this container
because i also have no idea
i've experienced these things and i can
definitely show you how to do them and
they've worked for me
and there's all this evidence that shows
how a group field can affect the
the quantum field um so it's more of
like
cool like asking people into this
container that have that knowing of like
non-physical reality
and that kind of they've maybe played
with creation a little bit themselves um
and and uh and then seeing what happens
like it's like oh
like like let's see what we can like
unlock together
um and prove what's possible together
and that could be the start of
something like huge um
you know like on a grander scale we've
seen when people do group meditations
how
the city like for world peace the city
like violence decreases and
you know you can call these things like
coincidence but um
some of these quantum experiments are
like very like
scientific and uh and how this actually
works
so um yeah it's kind of like a new age
approach to you could say like
empowerment or like tony robbins
things but mainly it's just my curiosity
and passion like
uh based on my experience guiding itself
because at this point it feels like
something i have to tell people
like i've done this ritual date with the
universe where i've asked for what i
wanted
um and things appear and it's like well
what the [ __ ] is that
and really quickly the inspiration and
this will make me sound crazy but i
don't care because reality is actually
crazy
um the inspiration for the bottle to the
universe i threw in the ocean
originated when i was a kid and this is
a great story
um i was in second grade and this kid
came up to me and he said hey i know how
to make anyway she want come true
and i was like what and he had it was a
group of my friends in the circle and he
had these little bottles with corks in
them that were really tiny
and he said you go home and put food
coloring in this water and sugar
and pour it on your trampoline at sunset
and ask for any wish you want to come
true and it will
and he told me this with like such
conviction and complexity that i was
like
[ __ ] like i felt like i just got a
golden
genie [ __ ] lamp or something so i put
it in my pocket
took it home um put red food coloring in
it sugar water
went out to my trampoline at sunset and
i was like okay
like i was by myself like what am i
gonna wish for what do i want
and uh i wish i was huge into pokemon at
the time so obviously i was like well
i want pokemon to be real and i was
imagining like i don't know like a
charizard i was like oh that might be
too scary
but i'm like okay i just want to see
what happens so that child like
curiosity and playfulness
poured it on the trampoline it asked for
pokemon to be real and then
a couple days later as a kid me and my
brother shared this bunk bed
and we both shared this memory to this
day and he could tell you this you can
attest to my experience or our
experience
but we woke up and outside of our window
through these blinds that you could kind
of see silhouettes through was
three pokemon like pikachu like it was
clefairy it was like pink so it was
either coffee or jiggly puff
and then squirtle and we both woke up
as kids and we're like what the [ __ ] is
that like
what the [ __ ] is that like what the [ __ ]
is that
and so he kind of stood there in this
silence that held so much tension
and like this isn't supposed to be real
um and we kind of turned our
the other cheek and like went to bed and
um but we both share that memory to this
day so
what was that like okay cool to me that
was like the field or like
multi-dimensional beings basically
saying hey we hear you we see you like
you know this is possible um and so
that's where
this this like com that was the first
time i ever actually had a conversation
in agreement with the universe where i
believed
and i planted a seed into the field or
my subconscious that things could be
made manifest
because my conviction was so high and
and so
the idea is to bring that energy into
the the workshop um and to like play
with
like your destiny or like creation in a
way that's personal
to you and a way that shows you that
more is possible
um so yeah we'll be doing like a
manifestation ritual or kind of ceremony
where uh you have this date or this
conversation with the universe
where you can ask it for what you want
and and let it go
and trust that you will receive it which
most people don't even dare to do
in their lifetime so that's that's uh
that's like the nature
of the course the idea
those little dates with the universe
with an experiment
experiential activity are fantastic
like the bottle in the ocean or the
balloon with the message like this is
great stuff yeah cool way to play with
creation it's fun
yeah yeah and it and it um
it deepens one's
relationship to this infinite
possibility and manifestation as we've
been saying which is great
um to all these awakening higher
possibilities it's
fantastic and so
do you have an approximate idea of when
you feel like
imagine will be ready and people can
access it via the links in the bio below
or
um both keelan's website and his
instagram cool yeah so i can uh
i'll put like an email a spot for people
to enter their email on my website to
stay like updated on it
but i feel like it's gonna be in july
perfect
yeah perfect sometime in july for that
and then um
and you guys can visit the
links in the bio below this is uh
keelan's instagram
and he has another art page there as
well it's two two two two followers
good catch two two two two that's right
that's right from my synchronicity
freaks out there and so he
writes uh he's got a lot of good like
videos on here as well and
um he's got he writes a lot of good post
content
and then you can find more of his uh
photography
and content on his website as well
and
awesome yeah dude thank you
love you bro i love you
thanks for sharing this moment in time
it's cool
yeah we played beautifully here
for sure for sure yeah
cool thanks everyone for tuning in
would love for you to let us know how
you feel in the comments below on the
episode leave us a comment
also if the video brought you value give
it a like uh subscribe to the channel
also share the video with other people
like you that you feel this would be
influential for and go and give keelan a
follow on instagram
go and uh check out his website as well
the links are in the bio below
his imagine course approximately july so
get pumped for that
and get pumped to share that with other
people that you feel like
um are a good fit for the
infinite possibility space and
manifestation
and that's all infinite love
that's a wrap that's a wrap baby peace
out love you guys
and for the love peace later